was this jeffree star killed a yak yeah
what is that
i just knew that was gonna be a good ass
turn
this is what he's doing on his like
ranch lunch time with my star yet girls
[Music]
what the hell ah
yo yak meat
yo
first of all that's a great phrase for
your dick yep i'll fill your hole yak me
this is straight up like serial killer
move yeah this is psychopath [ __ ] how is
anyone how did anyone like this picture
that's crazy who the [ __ ] saw that
picture was like yeah my boy yeah my boy
is sociopathic lunch with my star
yak girls
that's so wild that's so [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] to post that knowing
that you're gonna slaughter them with my
star yeah girls she's like petting him
kissing him
so he sells yak meat now as a business
endeavor yeah
wait that's what it's looking like
damn
what a pivot man seriously from makeup
to yak meat yeah jeffrey does it all
does he still do like youtube and makeup
stuff yeah it's like how to kill a yak
yeah yeah
slaughtering my star yak yeah damn
wow and i wonder if he advertises his
yak meat on his youtube video i think he
will definitely begin to yak meat i kind
of want to try some yak meat
should we cough some and do a taste test
no
i don't think it's yaks in those
packages dude you don't think so no what
do you think it is human human meat yeah
yeah i mean the
the youtuber to yak meat producer
pipeline
yeah like what is that i mean
it's a pretty you know commonly like did
he want
did he go it is you know on an exotic
you know like animal hunting tour
and then did he just
you know put a [ __ ] 50 cal shell
through a yak and he was like
can we eat that
yeah and the guy's like yeah we do the
[ __ ] ever we're like breaking federal
laws right now
[Laughter]
but it's my property so it's cool you
could do more with it if you want and do
whatever you want to do whatever you
want stop using the same regurgitated
quote from last year when i said
all of my yaks are pets they are but
months later i learned how healthy yak
meat is i started to appreciate learning
where my food comes from educate
yourself
and not immediately lash out they are
pets the fact that he still said they
are they they are no no it's more evil
let's get one thing straight they are my
pets
and i will do with them as i please
i can lead it out to pasture i can lead
it to death i can [ __ ] cut it up and
eat it if i so please yeah now but now
all of a sudden it's immoral to eat your
pets i'm sorry
where else is it gonna go
just die and
you know whatever i see no conflict i
chose to create a cosmetics line that
doesn't torture and test on animals we
all know i've never claimed to be vegan
it's about evolving in the beauty
industry and moving past the old ways so
his makeup stuff is cruelty free
but has he started slaughtering his
cruelty full
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
i mean how clear is it that cruelty free
is just a marketing term yeah
cruelty full
yeah cruelty full yeah
yeah
yeah these guys when he flips it over
this yak was murdered with an axe
slowly and painfully and then top
started at the back
the last few moments of this yak were
horrendous oh mike just know you are
eating pain and sorrow
but i've raised it you know wag you yeah
this is the opposite
[Laughter]
that's just a bag of [ __ ] muscle and
blood that is
i love my pets
here's my pet's instagram
here's my
it's like yak harlow or something like
that
that's the instagram account name it's
just all ground up
chilling in the freezer with my daddy
hanging out with my dad in the freezer
just yeah just chilling on the beach
it's just a [ __ ] plate
with
me
it's just
on the [ __ ] beach
[Laughter]
dad loves eating me on the beach
me and daddy and he's just holding him
up like a [ __ ] picture just a pack of
meat
daddy giving me a massage
oh my god bro
that's literally just a bag of blood and
muscle fibers dog
bro just in the middle just in the
middle of like dying dude it really is
like this no no he was dying yeah still
here
jerky
oh god
i love when dad jerks me you watch
oh my [ __ ] god man yeah yeah
just try our fresh ground dog meat
he's like cody noel called me out for
dog logic and um i actually feel just
the same
i'm not a hypocrite i'm not a hypocrite
i'm gonna eat the [ __ ] out of this dog
i'm gonna kill this dog and put it in a
bag
going for a walk with my dad next one
going for a grind
i'm always on the grind with my dad yeah
there you go
that's what it is jesus christ dude join
us in the bonus for more animal murder
it really always comes back to this
doesn't it i mean always it's like
getting away so absurd dude staryak
ranch her ranch has over 120
yaks and we're gonna kill them all and
they're all [ __ ] dead
watch the journey of 120 acts going to
zero click on the story
damn i have to take a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
stop it go dude go back and then
just
oh iconic and then yeah iconic then go
to the next one yo what up i'm here at
the steak ranch keep this [ __ ]
wouldn't he so cute now look at this let
me tell you what's cuter than cute it's
more iconic than that picture this
[ __ ] burger right here
you know juicy
you know what's going to be iconic when
i eat him and [ __ ] him in the toilet
yeah i want i want cheeseburger i
actually have to think about this we can
keep this up in the bonus this is the
[ __ ] bad but i'm gonna go take a dump
all right everyone see you soon oh oh
yeah new merch yeah new merch studios.tv
and click the shop
and uh yeah go ahead yeah that's it
damn that jeffree star burger
you